and the guys welcome back to the games
with stage III 2015 I am joined by Dirk
from he was a flu bite hello hi we're
gonna be talking about you two we're
gonna talk about anno 2205 right so we
saw it at the press conference the other
day yeah what was the reaction like oh
we were we were super excited to be here
at e3 and to present our new
city-builder to the international public
and yes it was it was a very good
reaction afterwards we'd we took a look
and we were really proud of what we saw
Twitter feed just going mad yeah
absolutely so let's talk a little bit
about I know the series I mean it's
taking it's taking us through history
yeah and then we had 2017 it took us a
little bit into a scary global warming
in future yes yes you're right it was a
big change for the series because as you
said they were all in historical
settings before and was the first time
that we went into the future but this
topic with warming and the more critical
stuff that's over now with with the
newest installment of our future vision
this is more about exploration again
which is the core of the series so it's
a more positive approach we will go to
the moon and conquer moon yes we're
going even further not only is space
travel viable but building space
colonies yes yes that's true so we will
start on earth as usual but then we will
go beyond earth and we will make our
colonies on moon to make life on Earth
better so yeah so what you see here this
is the space part it's it's fully
upgraded so you see there's a space
elevator already going up and there's
some energy being transmitted from moon
to earth so this is really there's
already has been a lot of progress here
in the game so when you start this is
like a small building site and you have
to build this up supported with all the
infrastructure and supported with with
the big city and a lot of people mine
it's a big space but a lot of people
work in here so you have to earn your
way up to the moon so it's quite a task
for the players are up to I mean so why
why did you design it that way why
couldn't we just be dropped on the moon
oh yeah where we did a lot of a lot of
research at home obviously there's a
reason I mean we've been there in the
60s and we are not back on moon right
now so and so we asked the scientists
and people at university so well what do
you think of when could it happen and
they say yeah it will take some time
because getting us up there is really
expensive and there's a lot of
interesting resources for us to get from
moon but we have no way to harvest them
right now so we moved another 135 years
to the future so this is the time when
we can make it happen and the players
will have to build these cities that you
see to to set up the necessary
infrastructure so everything you see
here this is really just built by the
players this is just a safe game
somebody from our team played up it it
took him maybe a few days to build this
so yeah this time you can build really
big impressive cities on earth and then
later huge colonies on moon so it's all
about the players freedom and you can
see landscapes also have an impressive
size so players can really do everything
they wish so I mean let's start from the
very beginning then I suppose I want to
make a city how do I do it oh you want
to make what I want to make a city like
it's obviously it's city management city
building games there's resource
management to deal with its core it's a
city builder but it's it's also there's
marcher there's a lot of features linked
to the city building so what you can see
here there's a huge economic aspect to
the game so you have to set up the
necessary infrastructure to support your
people because this game is really about
caring about your people that live in
your city so they have needs and you
have to set up the infrastructure and to
to give them everything they need so
they are happy and they will pay you
more money and you can set up bigger
bigger operation so that's like the
basic gameplay circle are there gonna be
factions yes there will be factions but
this is part of one of the new features
they are not part of one game play
session because this was too complex in
the last game for a lot of players so
there are still more factions but they
are separated in different game worlds
so you have like the moon people living
in the Luna do not colony so there's -
officer stuff like that and on earth you
have like the normal people living on
earth and they are supported from the
moon guys stuff like that yeah awesome
so let's talk a little bit about life on
the moon yeah because I mean it's gonna
be very different I remember reading
that because the moon you know
it's susceptible to asteroids and they
eat debris flying around how do we save
our precious Moon City yes that's that's
really different so what do you see here
like this nice earth cities this is
something unknown is totally different
there's no really big metropolis is up
there there's colonies so little why we
will see a moon colony um so you'll be
able to see that it's a more hostile
environment up there so it's really
about protecting what you built there so
I know is a protective game so you
really build up something and you have
to care for it on earth it's easier
unknown it's more difficult as you said
there's no atmosphere on moon so
everything that drops on the surface has
a big impact and destroys everything you
built there so you have to set up a
shield generators for example to protect
you everything you build and then also
your people will suffer from radiation
and stuff like that so you have to build
up a Medical Center and support them and
stuff like that so we did a lot of
research on this what you can see here
is ha this is the moment when when in
the game the player will be able to
leave Earth behind and if I find his way
up to the moon
so this is a big moment for the player
and then you see here these are like
different worlds you can enter so
there's a strategy map and you see they
are all combined so they're all running
at the same time and you can choose
between them any way you want so you can
leave behind one game world and go into
another one for example switch between
Earth and Moon and there's no loading
screen or something you can just while
the other session is loading you can
continue to play the game on a strategic
level set up your routes or take a look
at at your goods and do all of this meta
game and so the game becomes more and
more complex while you played it starts
very easy but then for the advanced
gamers it's
a complex a strategic game and here we
are then on the moon and you see there's
a space part on moon - it's this one
it's also nearly fully upgraded but you
see the moon it's really different
environment no animals no Wi-Fi yes it's
a more mystical it's it has a totally
different approach from from the look
and feel also a politics become rough up
there because people really want their
share of the moon so you as a new
corporation being up there you are
really not welcomed by them so the
competition gets rough up there and here
you see one of these moon colonies they
are built inside the creators because
the craters on the moon they are the
more protected areas so this is all
there we did a lot of research and on
the sites of the craters you see that's
a lot of mining going on so that's why
we are up there to to mine the moon I
mean so let's talk a little bit about
what way mining I mean cuz it has to be
especially if we're gonna go all the way
up absolutely that's what we were asking
the scientists were why why should we go
up there and they said oh there's some
interesting things to be found on the
moon the first one is the helium-3 it's
an isotope where we can create energy
from fusion energy that could be
something in the future to solve our
energy problems back on earth
so that's something the players will be
able to do and also on the moon there's
a mineral layer called creep below the
moon dust and you will be able with
giant harvesters to to harvest the moon
surface and to get your hands on on the
creep so that stuff the players can do
and then in the end they will become
self-sufficient as you can see here with
these biosphere so in the beginning you
will be getting up everything onto the
moon and it's very expensive to support
your - up there but later they will be
able to be become self-sufficient and
then send back all the precious stuff
down to earth so that's that's a huge
part of the game to become
self-sufficient on moon so I'm
interested - this is you know this is my
moon city things going fine what's
happening on earth is that in a
suspended or is it everyone no no you
don't you don't suspend earth it's it's
still your home planet of course they
are connected so in the end you will be
even able you will be able to set up a
little moon tourism so one of the
stories of of this a big campaign that
is the the main narrative of the game
you will be able to set up a moon hotel
for the upper class so they want to
visit the moon yeah and and and to see
well I've been there you know in the
moon hotel so players can can do this
but here you see yeah this is our like
the the creep harvesters mining the moon
surface and getting all the stuff done
so it's more a moody a more mystical
place but you don't abandon earth of
course what you see here these fusion
reactors they they bring back the energy
for example down to earth by a micro
transmitter so it's it's there to
support Earth and then if you have the
support from moon you can build like
really big cities back on earth world
with thousands of buildings with
millions of inhabitants so it's a real
symbiotic relation so they are connected
and that's the principle of this game so
all these different game worlds they are
connected by the player and he can set
his focus wherever he wants so he can
focus on building really big moon
colonies or he says no I like I like the
mony to support Earth and build big
metropolis on earth it's all up to the
players this is really a sandbox game
with narrative elements but the player
is the king his freedom is the most
important thing here so you mentioned
you mentioned a narrative are you gonna
keep it going into any details about
that yeah we were going to details later
on that but there there is a main
narrative in the game even though it's a
sandbox game so you're starting as the
underdog corporation being called to to
Aluna licensing program so you take part
in that to get a license to be able to
go up to moon and as I said once you're
up there the competition gets real hard
and there's even some evil guys showing
up and yeah you will be able to save the
world of course in the end but I'm I
will talk about that later because
there's still some way to go until
November 3rd when this game is gonna be
released this year wonderful deck thank
you so much for joining me cannot wait
to play later this yeah thank you thank
you guys make sure you stay tuned here
in the game so it stays we've got more
awesome games coming up here from e3
2015